well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look then at what
is on the front pages as they come in
in the next half hour or so we will see
what's making the headlines with
the consultant editor of the daily mail
andrew pearce
and the associate editor of the daily
mirror kevin mcguire lovely to see you
both
to see you as ever though front pages
then starting with the metro
its headline sleaze is back echoing
secure stamina's comments on david
cameron's involvement
in the green cell lobbying controversy
telegraph carries warnings from the head
of the civil service that senior
government officials
with second jobs in the private sector
must
fully declare their interests the eye
carries an exclusive they say about a
senior member of the uk's lobbying
watchdog who it claims is
a lobbyist himself the guardian
understands that the equality and human
rights commission believes the
implementation
of so-called covet passports would be
unlawful because people wouldn't be
treated equally
the financial times has word of the
crypto currency
firm coinbase's debut on the nasdaq
share index
in the us and the daily star has heard
that dairy products are racist according
to climate activists
extinction rebellion more papers still
to come in
clearly andrew kevin are here to the
metro we start
andrew slees is back uh is that true
well look this is um labour want this to
stick because it's the last thing the
tories want under boris johnson
sleaze was something that dogged john
major's regime all those years ago
um it was it be deviled him uh every
other month it seemed to be some tory mp
was either in a bonking
scandal or there was some impropriety
and there were resignations and
by-elections
um but this so far i think the tories
are trying to confine this to
david cameron now he's been gone a long
time five years
but what he did in my view uh
he has not does not pass the smell test
if that i think it stinks to high heaven
it's completely laudable for a former
prime minister
to intervene to suggest to former
colleagues
that there should be government for
financial assistance to try to stop a
company going under
particularly thousands and thousands of
jobs are at stake
it's completely inappropriate however to
do that covertly
by texting on private uh phone numbers
but what's really at the heart of this
camera knew
if he saved that company his fortune his
share options
would be worth anywhere between 45
million
to 60 million even tony blair didn't
manage that
in one deal and let's face it he's
earned tens of millions since he left
number 10. that's why it stinks uh did
rishi soon at know when he was being
bombarded
by the former prime minister how much
cameron potentially
hoped to earn from all of this he says
these figures are inflated
it hardly matters anna the fact is he
was in line for a huge
huge payout and he hadn't broken the
rules
because he was an in-house lobbyist if
he was an external lobbyist
he'd have broken the rules so it shows
the rules are ridiculous
and um yeah and and and so
um it's a mess uh and uh and labour are
going to play it for all they can of
course
yes indeed and i'll just going to ask
you that general point before we come on
to the details of what happens next
kevin
labour clearly a dog with a bone on this
one not surprisingly it feels like an
open goal
but it's april there are elections in
may do they sniff
electoral wins from this would it play
out amongst the public do you think
i think i think it will slowly labor
claim their focus groups are finding out
uh that it is beginning and with john
major it wasn't just one event it was a
whole
series of events and we've seen with uh
the vip
fast lane for uh cronies of conservative
party donors friends of
uh ministers who were getting contracts
so it's it's building on on that and the
metro headline sleazes back well
kierstalmer said tori sleezes back i
think he would have preferred that
as the full the full headline but
sleazes a potential to damage
uh boris johnson and the government
which is why the prime minister set up
the inquiry i think it's
possibly too early to have any big
impact
on the elections in in may in
scotland and wales and across england
various you know
everything from mayors of the west
midlands teas valley and
london councils to police and crime
commissioners
i think it's too early for that because
at the moment the government's getting a
vaccine bounce i think that's probably
going to be a bigger factor
but it is damaging and it is it is
corrosive and
dennis skinner was kicked out of the
house of commons when he called cameron
dodgy dave
i think he probably deserves an apology
now does mr skinner
so what happens next then let's go to
the ft
the treasury select committee has
announced it will investigate this
um despite labour's demands for a
broader parliamentary inquiry on this
uh obviously losing uh in the commons
today and who gets called and how
interesting does that get andrew
well and you know for a select committee
to call a witness
it is almost unheard of for anybody to
turn it down because the select
committee is effectively
one of the highest courts in the land so
cameron's spokesman
has put his head above the parapet for
only the second time in 40 days
significant wasn't it the cameron's
statement two and a half pages came out
uh this weekend just gone because of the
death was it because of the death of
prince
prince philip he decided to break his
silence because the sunday times had
some pretty good stuff about him but
sunak will have to give evidence
and he'll say what he did know what he
didn't do what and i think what she's
seen out so far
seems to be in the clear but the
evidence from david cameron will be
fascinating
because he'll be caught brought back to
the bar of the house he'll be given a
tough time
by boring mps too who will not be
grateful to their former leader for any
of this and of course some of the people
on that committee will hardly even know
david cameron because they probably
weren't even in the house
when he stood down in 2016. but dave
used to be a lobbyist you know or a pr
man
but a tv company called um kevin might
remember was it um
no the guy would see michael green he
worked for a man called michael green
but there were many journalists very
serious journalists
who said that when cameron did that pr
job shall i put it this way politely
he misled them uh he disassembled uh
so uh his whole past is coming back
he is a lobbyist uh and you can see why
he's not taken appearage in the house of
laws
because he'd have to disclose all sorts
of details about his income
uh and uh and how much money he really
did think he was going to make
45 million pounds is a huge amount of
money
no wonder he was sending desperate texts
to chancellors
other ministers and dragging poor old uh
matt hancock into all of this i thought
sorry for hancock actually he was a
a functionary in in david cameron's
office when he was leader of the
opposition
so then when he cameron calls in a favor
when he's secretary of state
when you come and see this bloke green
cell he goes to see him bobby doesn't
know much about it
hancock declared everything in the
proper way but cameron has just dragged
all sorts of people into this quagmire
i don't think it's going to sink the
tories and kevin's right it's not going
to damage them i don't think in the
run-up to these local elections
but it's an unwelcome distraction indeed
pandemic still being fought as we know
uh colton tv i think was was that the
one you were trying to
remember yes um so to the telegraph then
more broadly once again um kevin this
idea that mandarins have second jobs but
i think just
surprised many many commentators um and
they're all being sort of flushed out
are they is that is that the plan
yeah simon case the uh secretary wants
to know
who they are by the end of the week he's
not aware of it and of course it
came as something of a surprise to find
out the the government basically chief
procurement officer was double dropping
uh with uh green seal two on he's on his
way out for several months and then
ended up as a director and would have
made a lot of money too
if the company hadn't haven't collapsed
it's a bit like a it's a bit like
harry kane playing for spurs and then
you've got to sign for manchester united
and then he's playing for them as well
at the same time
it's astonishing because you're in
government you're purchasing services
you shouldn't then be working for a
company and that's selling those
services
it's utterly ludicrous now that's a
that's a kind of structural
problem that has to be fixed as well
it's not it's not just dodgy dave as we
should just call cameron
uh now it seems to be rather
rather wider than that but i could see
why
the prime minister doesn't want a wider
parliamentary committee
as as we've just heard will be the the
treasury committee on grill
rishi sunaka the public accounts
committee on all the public
administration committee
may grill david cameron but once you get
these
wider inquiries boris johnson will know
he will lose control which is why he
wants his own
inquiry by the lawyer with the
with the cabinet office so it doesn't
mean to say he'll publish it all and act
on it all if it comes along so what
happened with the
pretty patel bullying uh round we said
uh he
basically lost his uh his advisor on the
ministerial code because he wouldn't
uh he wouldn't act on that but it's uh
it's it's amazing how these things
blow up but it's taken five or six weeks
of pretty good
journalism by the ft and the sunday
times
to to get this far and i i agree with
andrew about it was wasn't it remarkable
that 1700 word statement from david
cameron he broke his silence of 30 days
or so
just after the duke of edinburgh has
died he knows it would be less attention
some of the oxygen of publicity would
have been taken away by the royal
royal funeral he's a penguin at the end
is dodgy
dear can i actually quick question
though if he hadn't been
if he hadn't stood to personally gain
would this
have all been all right do you think is
is the difficulty
the money that could have been made with
the saving of a company is that
so you're suggesting that prime
ministers should be able to lobby and
you know the idea of banning them from
lobbying forever and they can make money
on speaking engagements doesn't matter
in america
what i would say about that it's
entirely right for a former prime
minister to get involved in trying to
save a british company that might be
going under
uh but it's the way you do it you should
not be
using your private phone system
uh because you know the current chance
of this checker he was doing it covertly
behind the scenes he didn't want people
to
know what he was doing that's not the
way to do it there should have been
letters written
he should have been talking to civil
servants not sending little covert text
to his mates hoping
that people would jump to attention
because he used to be leader of the tory
party
it really is a grubby little exercise by
cameron actually that's what it's been
grubby
and greedy cameron himself uh
accepts that he should use more formal
channels now
now he's been caught red-handed but i
think it's the money
because he was doing it for his
enrichment he didn't show much concern
or sympathy for the steel industry and
steel workers when he was
prime minister and i think if a prime
minister former minister
was lobbying on behalf of the poor
wanting better housing
and they weren't financially involved
then i think that would be acceptable if
it was somehow altruistic if it was
philanthropic
if it was good charitable works all
areas that
cameron isn't uh primarily noted for
although when he's a
list of um of interest he did say he did
he did some work but basically he's just
been trying to make
big big books and this is a prime
minister who imposed austerity
reduced the bedroom tax made life a lot
harder for the
yeah and then all of a sudden snapped
deep in that
trough i think really peaceful
okay we'll need to get to a break
actually but um we will see what happens
it's going to be a fascinating select
committee when it uh when it comes
plenty more from you in just a moment uh
including a lot of debate over so-called
covert passports
could they be illegal uh talking about
that in just a moment
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview with me now andrew is
kevin mcguire
see how many stories we can squeeze in
uh shall we the guardian first of all
kevin
um this idea of covered passports and
the fact that they might not be legal
tell us more
yeah this is the equalities and human
rights uh commission
it says that it could be a result of in
indirect discrimination two-tier society
if there are certain ethnic groups
people of certain economic classes
who who don't uh have the certification
to use them they also say
they may be a proportionate response
to ezine lockdown so there's a little
bit of facing two ways but this
these are the legal problems that the
government has been grappling with for
for some time as boris johnson sometimes
seems to back him
to go to the pub and then he backs off
from them and you never quite know what
he's going to
going to do but i unders i can
understand that uh
the the concern but you would have
thought if they were really going to be
unlawful the the commission would have
just without with lawyers or lawyers
already i think they're they're kicking
around
the uh you know the thing too and i can
see i can see there's a problem but
there's less of a problem once everybody
is being offered and had the ability to
get
jabbed and this is it's on the back of
today
my hancock health secretary saying in
england maybe uh no job no job
in care homes where something like one
in five of staff
are still to be jabbed not all of them
will have refused but a fair proportion
or will have said no for various reasons
just quickly andrew did you want to come
in because i want to get you very
quickly on that
my view about these passwords look i
think they're going to happen i think
they're inevitable
i think they're an economic it'll be
driven by economics
nightclubs theaters those sort of things
they're going to do it
i've always been very wary of the
government imposing
a mandatory past what for those very
reasons the commission have mentioned
don't like the idea of the government
being nanny state telling us what we can
and can't do again
and it's not going to throw up legal
challenges so but i think they are
coming
and i think the commission should make
its mind up um quick 30 seconds andrew
i'm going to stay with you
no point talking to the republican on
this one necessarily which is the
photograph of
the duke of edinburgh with seven of his
great grandchildren balmoral 2018
and the decision at the paper reporting
and elsewhere
uh that uh about the dress code for
saturday which has been i know something
your paper's been pursuing
we have look this is a story that's very
interesting prince harry was determined
to wear
his military uniform he was a soldier
who saw active
service in afghanistan but he's not a
soldier anymore
he's lost all his honoree roles with the
military because of his decision
with his wife to walk away from his
royal duties prince andrew still has
honorary roles
so does prince charles so does princess
hand they'd all have been in military
uniform
he'd have been the only one who wasn't
prince andrew by the way wanted to wear
the uniform of a rear admiral because
he's an honorary one of those which
isn't quite appropriate
so the answer apparently is going to be
none of the mourners
will wear military uniforms and i think
that's very sad
because the one person who had a
genuinely really
big military career there was prince
philip who was mentioned in dispatches
in the second world war
he had a stellar career in the navy and
he would have liked i think
his sons to have been wearing military
uniform but this is what's happened
prince harry's still causing waves even
now
kevin i was going to do the weather but
i've run out of time i don't even have
time to hear what you're going to say
he's lost for words he's actually cool
it's definitely time to go
the whole royal family is about posing
isn't it if you if you've
a lot of people really want to watch it
and and pay tribute
um we'll see you at half 11. you can
talk about it then thank you both very
much indeed see you soon